after 26 years of working in operate
last year i decided to step out
and work something on my own
that's when i realized that there is a
need to up-skill because a lot of
current practices that's
different from what it used to be 10-15
years ago
and there's a need for me to
you know get into a formal way of
upskilling my skills
hi i'm anand i'm a co-founder at a
medtech startup i'm also founder of a
collaboration platform called
medtechhub.org
and i'm an alumni of simplylearn and
purdue university
i passed out of
i am kolkata in 1994 specializing in
marketing and general management
and worked in many organizations
including three top global med tech
companies
when i was actively looking for a
digital marketing course last year i
came across this course called
postgraduate
program in digital marketing from simply
learn
and i decided i would want to pursue
that
digital marketing has gone through a
rapid change
so when i decided to step out of the
corporate work and start on my own i
realized i need to up skill one of the
interesting thing about the online
course was that
since i was
beginning to work on my startup
and also didn't want to spend time away
from family it's sort of method
requirement
second is
i have a lot of hobbies okay i do
gardening i do wildlife photography and
bird watching and things like that
so having the classes in the evening in
the weekend released time for both the
daytime during the week as well as in
the weekend so i can continue to pursue
with the knowledge gained from the
course
i was almost immediately able to apply
it into my
website as well as the blog site what
this did to me is two things one it
reduced the amount of time i would
normally have to spend in in creating
that second is it was also more
effective in reaching the right customer
right audience one thing is very clear
you if you have to stay on the top
you have to continuously reinvent
yourself that also means upskilling
in everything that you do
it's a fast changing world and
competition is nipping at you all the
time so it's better to be
better skilled and appropriate skilled
than to lose out
[Music]